what happens when you place a credit  card into  scp-914 or the clockworks dr naysmith  decided to find out dr nae smith placed  his credit card into scp-914 on the  setting very fine the output was a  similar-looking credit card printed with  the phrase rank alph infinite money  privileges dr naysmith received a note  reading dr naysmith i didn't think i  need to remind you that scp-914 is not  to be used for personal financial gain  but it seems i was wrong consider this  an official warning dr coltrane he  placed the note itself into the  clockworks on the setting very fine the  machinery produced a note that instead  read dr naismith i didn't even think of  using scp-914 for personal financial  gain but that seems like a solid idea  consider this official permission to  reap the fruits of your labor signed  05-11